portugal is in the grip of a brutal heat
wave and its capital lisbon is
sweltering i think we all need to be
worried because when you are worried it
helps you to focus
patricia gaspar is portugal's secretary
of state for home affairs charged with
responding to extreme weather but also
focused on a much longer term emergency
climate change are not fake news they
are here they are for real and we need
to really change our mindset and prepare
ourselves for these new kind of events
heat waves will become more and more
frequent uh and we do need to prepare
not only in terms of the way we do
policies but also the way we teach
people how to deal with this kind of
events
and that's not just because of wildfires
and impacts on health
extraordinary heat is not only dangerous
but expensive because as well as the
cost of any emergency response people
are also understandably less productive
and so in a city like lisbon adapting to
that might mean changing working hours
to avoid the hottest parts of the day
learning to live with heat will be
different everywhere but for now in
portugal's national weather center
control room there's a crisis to monitor
this one this has this characteristic
that it's quite long with quite high
temperatures we have places in portugal
when we are going to have when this
episode ends
five six even maybe seven days with
temperature above 40.
all the more reasons say many to alter
activities and ways of life and to
accept a new reality
this is the way we should
face the next years or the next century
because the the climate change
projections are revealing um even darker
scenario from them from the the last
decades on the other this our century
that we are living so
we must adapt
as wildfires continue to tear through
parts of the country some might even
need to rethink where they live before
the next one comes
the pressures of climate change
reshaping our world
hannah thomas peter sky news in lisbon